look we need points in it all right I
don't mean this maliciously what the
word
a story
[Music]
Lord I'm sorry this life of sin I like a
sin this life's not for me
[Music]
done an amazing video touching on this
topic the reason I'm doing this video is
usually when I see a cold brother like
Marshall on the YouTube scene touched on
a topic I don't find the need to handle
is covered if it comes from an angle
that I haven't come from Handler but
this thing was actually very close to my
heart many of you guys might not know
but I was called the word yes I
used to live in London I used to get
into fights and all this kind of stuff
my dad took me outside London I used to
live in a place in North East
Lincolnshire and I was me and my friends
who were subject to racism day in day
out we used to get into fights every
single literally need it every single
day yeah be like a jacket used to go
clubbing Etc somebody coming there was
Taki when we're walking even my black
friends were called packing like the guy
was so bloody it was like you know if
you're gonna call me call me the n-word
at least I mean
both of them are wrong but we would I
would and I'm Turkish I'm Kurdish I'm
not even like it's irrelevant the point
is not that new or just because you're
Pakistan no I used to be called these
things well like I cannot tell you the
amount of times I got into fires I got
jumped all because of this and so much
so that I was even in the local
television the newspaper because we had
a big fight against these race thugs all
the brothers from different ethnicities
that we where we used to live we came
together and then they outright brought
like literally a fight about 30 40 of us
against 50 60 of them alhamdulillah they
got sparked uh just to be and I'm not
even boasting if you read the telegraph
okay
Grimsby Telegraph okay I actually tried
to get in contact with them to find the
article yeah yeah they kind of got
balanced hands and from that day on what
they did not even come near us they put
some respect and after that day once we
show them you know they say that once
you show your teeth once we show them
you know alhamdulillah we all of us came
together
um the Africans the Jamaicans Lebanese
Turkish Kurdish Pakistani Bengali we all
came together so much trouble was on the
local newspaper uh subhanallah and even
then the new local newspaper made it
seem as they were attacking a group of
white men for no reason they were racist
individuals subhanallah so I know this
and not only that when I used to live in
the same place I was younger they
smashed my house they broke all the the
wooden shed thing in the front he had
the gates they smashed that they came
and smashed my windows me and my mom my
brother was small I can remember that
that was like a trauma I can remember
they're trying to get into the house to
attack us literally I will hold I was
holding the door I remember these things
subhanallah and for someone like KSI to
trivialize it it's like me saying the
n-word yeah and trivializing what they
went through well lie this is so sad you
don't know like zeeshan said many of the
people they used to tell me stories what
they used to go through we we had so
many people go through racism yeah
racism because of their background so it
is disgusting and I don't know if it's
not a public apology but while I I
myself as a Kurdish man from Turkey I
was subject to this harassment this
bullying being attacked for years on end
and I know how it feels that when you
walk with your family you don't feel
safe who's gonna say what it's
disgusting it is disgusting brother
sisters well lie that's all I wanted to
say about my sister inshallah may Allah
protect us and may Allah deal with
racism which is directly connected to
Iblis yes of thinking you are better
than someone else just because of the
race the color or whatever it may be
inshallah alhamdulillah Islam has come
to abolish racists and brothers and
sisters may Allah bless you guys have an
amazing Ramadan salaam alaikum